what is going on guys so every once in a
while I like to do something called an
opinion piece basically what it is is I
give you my opinion on a subject that
I've been thinking about that has
something to do with movies or video
games in the past my last one that I did
was why gaming needs help I like to do
these every once in a while and
basically what I want to talk about
today is the current state of action
movies and the way they're made now I
want to preface everything I'm about to
say with the fact that I am NOT mr.
know-it-all movie King man who knows
everything I just love movies I love to
talk about them I'm flattered you guys
like to watch my videos but I'm not
trying to say that I am the guy that
knows everything that's wrong with
Hollywood or something it's just my
opinion about the way movies are made
nowadays specifically action movies and
the way they make action scenes because
I think there is a serious problem going
on and it needs to be corrected now see
there's some movies in the past few
years that have come out that have had
fantastic action sequences some of the
ones that really stick out of my mind
are the raid one of the things that made
that movie so great is the way the
action was filmed and the stunt work
that was done these guys knew what they
were doing they were obviously extremely
well prepared with their choreography
and were very physically strong and
capable of doing the things that their
characters did in the script now I asked
you guys on Twitter what examples you
wanted me to talk about and by far the
biggest one that people said was Alex
Cross do you guys remember the fight
scene and Alex Cross to this day that is
the worst fight scene I have ever seen
in my life in my review I said to their
credit that Tyler Perry and Matthew Fox
were really trying in their roles and
his actors they were both really trying
to give that movie way more credit than
it deserved but that fight scene
directed by Rob Cohen most famous for
his first fast in the Furious movie was
appallingly bad because the shakey cam
in it was in no way stylistic it didn't
add anything to it it was the worst
example of using the cameras shaky cam
effect to hide the fact that these guys
are not doing their own stunts
convincingly at all it was literally as
if the director instructed the cameraman
to just move the camera up and down
really fast
and we'll cut it together and we'll add
some sound-effects and that will
subconsciously tell the audience members
that people are getting hit in the face
that was truly awful and I specifically
remember sitting in that theater my
mouth just on the ground another one
that people wanted me to mention was a
good day to die hard or die hard five
more the worst sequels ever directed by
John Moore who typically is not a very
strong director at all he really hasn't
made anything much of merit and like I
said I'm not the guy who's been out in
Hollywood trying to make movies I've
just made probably two or three hundred
short films in the course of my short
life on this planet but that doesn't
mean that I still can't have an opinion
because I have watched so many action
scenes over the course of my life and I
have actually directed a lot of action
scenes on a very small limited budget
I've made movies in the past I made a
couple Indiana Jones fan films where we
had fight scenes and we tried to do our
best to make it look convincing one of
the biggest things that I learned from
watching some of the earlier action
films from like the 80s and the 90s
where Y takes use wide takes actually
show your actors doing things that looks
real actually have an actor who knows
what he's doing like Tom Cruise for
instance there is not an actor working
today at his level of Fame that commits
as much as he does to action scenes I
mean remember Mission Impossible Ghost
Protocol that's one of the biggest
action movie hits we've had in the past
ten years that was directed beautifully
by Brad Bird with wonderful wide long
takes of incredible stunt work that Tom
Cruise performed himself that's why that
movie was so enthralling to watch
because you actually were watching
someone doing the things that it says in
the script that the character is doing
and that's why it was so cool because
you could see him on top of the Burj
Khalifa actually doing that I'm not
saying every actor has to do
death-defying stunts to make their roles
interesting but Tom Cruise no one runs
faster than him no one I mean the guy
runs like 20 miles an hour in his movies
and he has to become a joke that Tom
Cruise runs everywhere but seriously
whenever I see a running chase scene
about to happen and Tom Cruise is
involved My Blood starts pumping because
that guy sells it Brad Birds direction
of Mission Possible for was flawless in
its execution that is a perfect example
to look at how actions should be
directed now
days with skillful use of CGI with a lot
of practical stuff as well so what do
you guys think are some of the best
action films ever made in my opinion
some of them are like the original
Indiana Jones trilogy some of the best
stunt work ever put to screen and it had
an actor who did a lot of that stuff
himself and made it convincing in a
director who understood how to film
these action scenes I mean nowadays
everyone tries to cut like three times
whenever someone moves but look at the
shot in the Last Crusade look at that
stunt guy just jumping from a horse onto
a tank how awesome is that and all it is
is a simple locked down wide take but
you are watching a man jump from a horse
onto a tank you're actually watching
that happen or how about this shot
Harrison Ford himself as well as a stunt
man being dragged behind a truck that is
happening that's actually taking place
these are the stunts that stick in
people's minds these are the things that
people go wow I watched an experience
just now because they actually watched
people risking their lives and again I
am NOT saying that a stuntman or
director has to put their actors in
danger just get people who know what the
hell they're doing let's take a film
that many regard as one of the best
action films ever die hard
again another film by director John
McTiernan who knew what he was doing
tons and tons of beautiful wide shots
that really encapsulated the frightened
element of the character and even though
Bruce Willis didn't do like an absurd
amount of his own stunts the way John
McTiernan helmed that film was so
intense and not in a way that was faked
he didn't take the camera and shake it
up or add a whole bunch of little sparks
here and there to try to make something
seem intense he actually had his actors
fierce in those scenes where you really
felt the adrenaline of not just the
moment but these actors in the moment of
filming it now what has always been a
prime example of how to do action and
what is still a prime example is foreign
films a lot of people overseas are
absurdly good with action and I'm not
just talking about kung fu I'm talking
about the fact that a lot of those
filmmakers overseas do not have the type
of budget that America has for some of
these movies so they do have to do a lot
more of their stunt work and a lot of
stuff way more practically so you will
see a
more death-defying kind of stuff in
movies like Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon this is a perfect example of a
foreign film with incredible action that
was able to break through the mold of
that movie has subtitles I want to watch
that but it was very successful at the
box office as well as won many awards
because audiences like well filmed
action you can get an audience and have
them sit down and watch something like
die hard 5 and maybe they'll be
entertained or they'll feel like the
time passed whereas you watch a truck
just pummel cars for 15 minutes and like
I said in my everything that's wrong
with die hard 5 video is filmed by a
team of monkeys I don't really know what
was going on there and the people can
walk out and they can say ok I passed
the time but when you sit them down and
show them an incredible action film or a
great adventure film that one summer
experience they're going to remember
that is when the audience members go
online they start writing loud that was
amazing or they write reviews of it they
get inspired to talk about it with their
friends and I'm saying this as if I'm
talking to Hollywood execs out there if
one of them happens to actually watch
this video stop hiring people who don't
know what the hell they're doing
seriously like we are fans of movies
this is a community of people who love
to go to the movies and watch great
entertainment they don't want to just
shell out 10 bucks and sit there and
watch Tyler Perry and Matthew Fox
fighting and have it look like garbage
we want to watch something that is done
with skill we want to watch someone who
has passion for filmmaking and people
who are in front of the camera who had
that same passion who want the audience
to have fun and enjoy the ride I mean do
you guys remember films in the early 90s
like Terminator 2 or speed these are
action classics why why are these
classics because someone knew what they
were doing
someone actually made these movies with
skill they filmed a bus go over a gap in
a bridge you know Terminator 2
revolutionized special effects and CGI
work but there isn't actually as much
CGI in Terminator 2 as you may think
quite a bit of the most memorable
moments are completely practical in
every way but by far the biggest thing
that people wanted me to talk about the
most when I mentioned this on Twitter
was the use of shaky cam shaky cam
in my opinion has become an epidemic in
Hollywood and when I say epidemic I'm
not even using that word lightly I mean
epidemic there is a disease spreading
through Hollywood filmmaking and that is
shaky-cam it's not cool
nobody likes it there is literally one
director working today that I can think
of that actually does shaky-cam
and makes it awesome and that is Paul
Greengrass the man who helmed Bourne
Supremacy Bourne Ultimatum Green Zone
and Captain Phillips this guy knows how
to use shaky cam and he knows how to use
it as a style and he knows how to use it
where it's appropriate he also has
people editing his films that are
extremely good at editing he doesn't
mask poor storytelling or poor stunt
work with shaky cam like some films do
he uses it as a stylistic expression for
the moment that he's trying to convey in
the film so where did this really get
started where did it get popular well
that would be Bourne Identity Bourne
Identity was a humongous hit and it
featured shaky-cam and quick cut editing
however it was done with skill now this
one was not directed by Paul Greengrass
it was made by Doug Liman who later made
mr. and mrs. Smith and it has this
year's edge of tomorrow coming out there
are people out there who can do
shaky-cam convincingly that is why it's
an art form sometimes it's done for
other things as well like Spielberg
really pioneered it with Saving Private
Ryan to show the horrors of war and it
was fantastic but nowadays directors
seem to think well you know what
everything needs about three or four
takes as someone moves like taken two
directed by Olivier Megaton or however
you say his name he's also directing
taken three which is fantastic I'm
assuming this one Liam Neeson will drop
a nuke on a foreign country to allow his
daughter to find him she threw grenades
off rooftops
I mean well if there was a baby down
there where if she exploded a baby with
a grenade that happened in a movie by
the way taken - yeah it was a big hit
made a lot of money now there are two
different styles of filmmaking that a
lot of people get confused in my opinion
that is shaky-cam and handheld cam two
very different things
handheld cam is just that it's a guy
holding the camera shaky cam is a guy
shaking the camera a very good example
of hand hell
kamme working fantastic in an
action-movie is collateral a movie that
michael mann directed who really
understands LA and the beautiful
nightlife of all of that and he really
really sold that fantastically in
collateral there isn't any shaky-cam in
collateral really it's mostly handheld
and that stuff is beautifully done
shaky-cam is different that's a very
very different thing and like I said
it's a disease and it needs to go away
the last thing I want to talk about is
something that also is happening quite
often in movies lately and that is
editing a film or filming it in a
certain way to obtain the rating that
you want the Primus taganga which was
filmed with quite a bit of shaky cam
because it was kids killing kids and
they wanted it to be pg-13 so they
couldn't show too much of that happening
so they adopted this filmmaking style
that seemed to cut a lot of the more
intense moments of the book out of the
movie now I understand their reasoning
they want to make more money they want
more people to see the movie they want
to get a return on their investment but
it didn't make anybody happy I mean
nobody watched that movie and said wow I
love the way that looks
ah it looks so good now I enjoyed the
first Hunger Games film for what it was
going for I loved the second one but the
first one had a filmmaking style that
really got under my skin and no one I've
ever talked to went yeah I love the way
they filmed that movie and that's the
point I'm trying to make yes I
understand the reasoning behind the
Hollywood execs and the director who or
whoever said we need to make that movie
and kind of mask some of the more
disgusting parts I understand the
reasoning I'm just saying it didn't
really please anybody so what's the
point let's get back to where we were
making incredible action films quite
often I mean it really wasn't that long
ago the nineties had quite a bit of
Awesome action films mean the matrix the
matrix for goodness sakes the Wachowski
brothers were attributing Asian and
kung-fu films they obviously grew up on
and they did a fantastic job with it you
saw actors in the frame actually doing
fight scenes that were awesome that what
Charles Keyes sold the stunts in that
movie they knew when to show a wide take
when to cut to his face and when to have
a long take they knew how to do that
because as filmmakers they understand
action a lot of times nowadays Hollywood
is
firing dramatic directors to do action
scenes because they want a film to have
more realism and more heft to it which I
understand but some of these directors
just don't know how to film an action
scene and that's all there is to it so
those are my thoughts on the way that
action is going nowadays it is a
epidemic it is a disease and I hope that
it stops what do you guys think of the
way this is all turning out because
there are still those gems each year
that come out we were like wow that was
an action film and that really was done
well I'm really hoping the raid 2 is
going to be that because it's looking
awesome and I've heard nothing but good
things about it but as a society we need
to stop accepting these poorly done
action films because we're giving them
our money and we would like a return on
our investment and our investment is
that we go there saying I hope this
movie's awesome and then it gives me
something to remember and it inspires me
in some way that's what we're investing
in you when we give you our money so
let's make some awesome action films
Hollywood let's get it started
so guys let me know below some action
films that perhaps I have not seen that
are more new that you guys actually
think are done well because I'd like to
watch them
I'm tired of the shakey cam dumb stupid
action that we are getting lately let me
know you guys think of my opinion on
this matter as always guys thank you so
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
Oh